welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and with the Wolverine being confirmed
to be part of Marvel studios's Deadpool
3 production excited nerds everywhere
who have been putting plastic knives in
between their fingers are wondering just
how the fox Universe X-Men are going to
factor into the overall MCU narrative
and just when they'll start to connect
well well my beautiful nerd baby
brothers sisters and gender label
resistors what if I told I told you that
Loki season 2 you could be that very
connection to the fox hero Multiverse
that we've been waiting for and that the
Loki season 1 finale could hold a secret
hint to that very link that might serve
to bridge these two realities together
let us dive into it together speculation
Nation but first do not forget to hit up
new rockstarsmerch.com to pick up our
newest latest Obsession shirts inspired
by both She-Hulk and house with a dragon
but they are only available for a
limited amount of time so hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com today to pick them up
so you can own them forever because once
they're in the vault it's easier to get
into the TVA than to get into the new
Rockstar results let's just say that in
this video is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform for
building your brand more on them later
alright gang so I think that King the
Conqueror was the very person who could
have given us the biggest hint as to how
the fox X-Men will initially factor into
the overall Marvel Cinematic Universe
plan specifically when he remains is
telling both Sylvie and the Loki whose
neck wasn't turned into a fine powder by
Thanos about his discover every of the
Multiverse and he uses a particular
imagery to illustrate this point roll
the clip before the TVA a variant of
myself lived on Earth in the 31st
Century then he discovered that there
were universes stacked
on top of the Zone wait did you see that
because when Kane notes that he
discovered universes stacked on top of
each other he specifically uses the
imagery of universes with a large black
hole at their very center doesn't that
look like the very beginning of the Loki
season 1 finale you know when we get
that massive zoom out of what appears to
be two universes before the camera
quickly zooms into the black hole on the
right and reveals that the Citadel at
the end of time and the entire secret
timeline of the MCU resides within the
right black holes very epicenter do you
remember that because I do I firmly
believe that this is because these two
black holes depicted in this finale
represent two separate cinematic
universes each with their own separate
Citadel their own separate sacred
timeline and their own separate TVA
Force you know like the completely new
TVA that we last left Loki in to be
arrested by Mobius and b-15 who have
never seen what ate Tom Hiddleston Loki
even looks like like think about it this
is Mobius and Mobius that we're talking
about here the Loki expert who knows
everything about Loki's if this Moby is
at the very end of the Loki finale is
part of a TVA that doesn't even know
what a Loki face looks like there were
likely any version of the TVA that
manages a Multiverse that doesn't even
have a Tom Hiddleston Loki in it and I
believe that this new TVA could
potentially be the TVA for the fox X-Men
sacred timeline and guys it's October
which means we're all feeling a little
spookier than normal and when you think
of spooky things you tend to think of
abandoned places that are falling apart
like my life
[Laughter]
abandoned mansions abandoned hospitals
and the spookiest of them all abandoned
websites your website does not have to
be spooky though Squarespace is the
all-in-one platform that makes it easy
to create update and maintain a
beautiful online presence for your
business you don't want your website
looking like something that was
hard-coded into HTML back in 1998 two
years before the world would end in Y2K
you want it looking and functioning like
the cream of the 2022 crop and
Squarespace can help you do that
Squarespace has a bunch of great
features to help your business be
successful you can present members only
gated content create email campaigns or
add online booking for appointments or
sessions all from the Squarespace
interface we are in the future ladies
and gentlemen for me my favorite aspect
is the analytics section that's where
Squarespace makes it easy to dig into
what's working what's not and figure out
what levers you can pull to make your
business even more successful so head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com rock stars to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain that's squarespace.com new
rockstars for 10 off your first purchase
of a website or domain and thanks again
for Squarespace for sponsoring this
video because if you think about it if
he who remains views different realities
as black holes and we only really zoomed
into the black hole on the right where
he who remains and his Citadel reside
that it serves to reason to me that the
black hole on the left is a completely
separate reality entirely with its own
Citadel at the very center and
considering that Deadpool 3 is looking
like it's going to be a direct sequel to
Deadpool 2 a movie with a huge emphasis
on time travel and altering timelines
set in a super complicated and frankly
nonsensical Fox X-Men timeline with its
own weird branches I can truly see Loki
season 2 being a primer that explains
why Deadpool and cable were able to
cause so much Mayhem in their own box
X-Men multiversal timelines in this
black hole on the left because judging
by the very end of the Loki finale when
we first
new versions of Mobius and B15 it sounds
like their own separate sacred timeline
has begun branching just like he who
remains as mcu's secret timeline was
that's what 63 new branches in this unit
alone does he want us to just let them
all Branch well at this point how are we
even gonna stop it we can't and since we
know from Kevin feige himself that the
branching timelines now allow for the
previously restrictive rules of
space-time to become absolutely
unraveled and allowed for timeline
crossover events like Spider-Man no way
home and Multiverse Madness in the MCU
black hole now that the new TVA from the
finale is dealing with a similar thing
in their black hole this might just be
exactly how the events of Days of Future
Past and Deadpool 2 were allowed to
happen because the TVA that was
previously pruning and managing the fox
X-Men timelines are no longer doing that
and just letting them Ranch which is why
Wolverine cable and Deadpool were not
arrested so this all being said if this
neighboring Multiverse is indeed the fox
X-Men cluster of timelines and universes
then I suspect Loki season 2 to feature
some surprise cameos from Key Fox
timeline influencers like Xavier Magneto
and Jean Gray and of course the
mischievous timeline manipulators like
cable Deadpool and Wolverine all three
of whom would have been quickly arrested
by their TVA were not for the ensuing
temporal chaos and I think Marvel
Studios would do this mainly for the
direct purpose of trying to canonically
explain the nonsensical timeline that
Kevin feige and Marvel Studios have
inherited after Disney's acquisition of
20th Century Fox because having Loki
tumble through the X-Men timeline with
this new Mobius would be a great way of
making sense of the mess that fox made
with all of its conflicting storytelling
while also Bridging the Gap between
these two previously separate cinematic
universes before Deadpool 3 hits the
scene and breaks every record imaginable
my God that movie's gonna make so much
money but anyways thank you guys so much
for taking the time to watch this video
you can follow me at mastertainment on
Twitter if you want to see me tweet some
weird [ __ ] but most importantly you can
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
the internet and when you do on YouTube
make sure you hit notification Bell so
you can get notifications every time we
upload a video and of course do not
forget to hit up new rockstarsmerch.com
so you can buy one of our cool latest
Obsession shirts inspired by both shield
and House of the dragon or literally
anything else that we have we sell
stickers pins and all sorts of really
cool things so head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com today but yes thank
you guys so much for watching again I
love you guys so much and I'll see you
guys next time goodbye
[Music]